good morning Hank it's Tuesday as you
can tell from the great speckled walls
behind me I'm in an airport it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
today I'm going to answer questions
about love and sex when do you think
it's okay to lose your virginity you
know call me old-fashioned but I don't
think 34 year old men vlogging in
airports should decide when other people
have sex I like this guy and I think he
likes me back but I'm not sure how do I
find out for sure I'm gonna tell you
what I tell Henry several times a day
use your words just talk to him if you
start going out you're gonna have to
talk to him anyway there's a girl in my
school who I like but I don't exactly
know just ask or using your words you're
not an Avox weight or are you if you're
an Avox write it down what is your stand
on birth control pills I try not to
stand on birth control pills at all I
think it might decrease their
effectiveness how do you say no to sex
without offending your partner to answer
your question let's make a Venn diagram
let this circle be asshats and here are
people who get offended when you say no
to sex you think it matters how many
people someone has slept with no and it
particularly bothers me that women are
held to a different standard on this
front than men also it's such a weird
thing to care about like imagine if I
started eating Cheerios for breakfast
would cheerios be like on the 48 cereal
you've tried eating
I don't feel special well then screw you
Cheerios I can't go into the past and
uneat all those cereals but that doesn't
mean I don't genuinely enjoy your
whole-grain crunch how do I know if he's
the one I don't think there is one one
have you ever had a crush on a band
member let me answer your question with
a question is Toby Turner in a band
John do you ship wholock sometimes I
feel like you guys just make up words to
confuse me when is it too soon to say I
love you just remember you can't unring
that Bell have you ever wanted to
experience giving birth no I've seen
birth no yeah no no no no is there a way
to tell if he actually cares or if you
just want to hook up yeah is he a
douchebag the first time you saw the
Yeti did you think she was the one no
the first time I saw the Yeti she was in
eighth grade and I did not think I'm
gonna marry that eighth grader what do
you think of an Othello kind of love you
mean the kind where you beat up the love
of your life and then kill her I'm
opposed to it in your opinion is
premarital sex wrong I certainly don't
think there's anything inherently wrong
with premarital sex like for example
it's legal for gay people to be married
in some states but not in others and
it's a little bit ridiculous to say that
it's possible for gay people to have
morally justifiable sex in Vermont but
not in Mississippi frankly I don't
really see it as my job to tell people
who they should have sex with or under
what circumstances also this is an
awkward thing to talk about in
Airport people in the airport think that
I'm crazy the people in the airport
think that I'm crazy and maybe I am to
be fair what is the secret to a
successful marriage usual generosity
also it's nice if you can like the same
television programs
is it wrong to do gay stuff like just
kissing oh man your question makes me so
sad no of course it's not wrong if you
want to kiss someone and that person
wants to kiss you back that is awesome
and don't let anyone tell you you should
be ashamed about that people are so
ashamed about their sexuality but you
shouldn't be it's great I'm talking
about it in Terminal A of the
Indianapolis Airport on average what
animal takes the longest to copulate I
don't know but I do know that llama sex
lasts like two hours because male llamas
experience something called dribble
ejaculation how do I know these things
he loves me and I don't love him and he
won't take no for an answer
yeah then he doesn't love you he doesn't
even respect your right to choose your
own romantic partners is it weird that
I'm in college and I've never kissed
anyone not at all as evidenced by the
fact that your question was the most
thumbed up out of the hundreds I got on
Facebook how do you cover up a hickey
hickeys are still a thing I never
understood hickeys it's like I like you
so I'm gonna suck on your neck until
there's bruising how can I ask someone
if he's gay in a subtle way alright oh
yay a gay just ask them use your words
nerdfighters thanks to the great
questions Hank I have to go get on a
plane I will see you on Friday